>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARK, THANKS.
AND JOINING US NOW, THE U.S.
SURGEON GENERAL , VICE ADMIRAL
JEROME ADAMS.
ACTOR ADAMS, U.S. IS NOW
REPORTING 30,000 NEW CASES A DAY
AND I WANT TO PUT UP A CHART THA
CASES IN ITALY AND CHINA, WHICH
HAVE LEVELED OFF AND ARE NOW
GOING DOWN AND THE CURVE ON THE
FAR RIGHT THERE HERE IN THE
U.S., WHICH IS STILL IN THE
EARLY STAGES AND STILL HEADED UP
SHARPLY.
GIVEN THE COURSE OF THE DISEASE
IN CHINA AND ITALY AND THAT WE
ARE WEEKS OR MONTHS BEHIND THEM,
HOW BAD IS THIS EPIDEMIC GOING
TO BE IN AMERICA AND HOW LONG
WILL IT LAST?
>> Dr. Adams: WELL, IT’S
TRAGICALLY FITTING THAT WE ARE
TALKING AT THE BEGINNING OF HOLY
WEEK BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO BE
THE HARDEST AND THE SADDEST WEEK
OF MOST AMERICANS’ LIVES, QUITE
FRANKLY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR
PEARL HARBOR MOMENT, OUR 9/11
MOMENT ONLY IT’S NOT GOING TO BE
LOCALIZED, IT’S GOING TO BE
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND I WANT AMERICA TO UNDERSTAND
THAT.
BUT I ALSO WANT THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PUBLIC,
ALONG WITH THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY
OF THIS EPIDEMIC.
YOU MENTIONED ITALY AND SPAIN.
THEY HAD A VERY, VERY HARD TIME
AND THEY ARE STILL HAVING A HARD
TIME, BUT THEY SEEM TO HAVE
REACHED THEIR PEAK AND ARE
COMING BACK DOWN ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
YOU SAY WEEKS, MONTHS, BEHIND.
I WOULD ACTUALLY BOOKS BACK A
LITTLE BIT.
WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THEIR TRAJECTORY FROM ABOUT A
MONTH AGO IS WHEN THEY REALLY
STARTED TO LEAN INTO THEIR
AGGRESSIVE MITIGATION EFFORTS.
THERE REALLY AGGRESSIVE
MITIGATION EFFORTS SO I WANT
AMERICANS TO UNDERSTAND THAT AS
HARD AS THIS WEEK IS GOING TO
BE, THERE IS A LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL.
IF EVERYONE DOES THEIR PART FOR
THE NEXT 30 DAYS.
WE ARE SEEING WASHINGTON, WHERE
THEY STARTED, DOING A MUCH
BETTER JOB.
CALIFORNIA’S TRAJECTORY HAS
LEVELED OFF, SO THERE IS HOPE,
BUT WE CAN’T ALL DO OUR PART.
>> Chris: LET’S TALK ABOUT
MITIGATION, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT’S TOP HEALTH ADVISORS,
INCLUDING YOU, SAY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO, ALL
OF US, IS TO STAY AT HOME, AND
YET THERE ARE STILL NINE
STATES -- THERE ARE STILL NINE
STATES WITH MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS THAT STILL HAVE NOT
ISSUED STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ASKED ABOUT
THAT THIS WEEK, HERE HE IS.
>> THE GOVERNORS KNOW WHAT
THEY’RE DOING.
IF THEY’VE BEEN DOING A GREAT
JOB.
I GUESS WE ARE CLOSE TO 90%
ANYWAY.
AND STATES THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ARE NOT IN JEOPARDY.
I WOULD LEAVE IT TO THE
GOVERNORS.
>> Chris: BUT DR. ADAMS, THE
CORONAVIRUS IS NOT A STATE ISSUE
ISSUE, IT DOESN’T FOLLOW OR
RESPECT STATE BORDERS.
DR. FAUCI SAYS HE BELIEVES THERE
SHOULD BE A NATIONAL
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER.
IS HE WRONG?
>> Dr. Adams: WELL, CHRIS,
IT’S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT MOST PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
OVER 90% OF THE COUNTRY IS
STAYING AT HOME AND A GOOD
PROPORTION, MORE THAN AVERAGE,
STAYING HOME EVEN IN THOSE NINE
STATES BUT THE LAST TIME YOU AND
I TALKED IT WAS ABOUT OPIOIDS.
PEOPLE DON’T KNOW, BUT I’VE RUN
A STATE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH,
I’VE BEEN INVOLVED IN HEALTH FOR
YEARS AND THEY DON’T RESPECT THE
STATE LINES BUT WE LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WHERE WE HAVE A SYSTEM
OF FEDERALISM AND WHEN IT COMES
TO OPIOIDS, STATES HAVE
DIFFERENT RULES AND REGULATIONS
AND LAWS REGARDING TREATMENT,
REGARDING SYRINGE SERVICE
PROGRAMS AS YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT.
I ACTUALLY PUT OUT A REPORT ON
TOBACCO EARLIER THIS YEAR AND WE
KNOW THAT STATES HAVE DIFFERENT
LAWS THERE AND MORE PEOPLE WILL
DIE EVEN IN THE WORST
PROJECTIONS FROM CIGARETTE
SMOKING IN THIS COUNTRY THAN ARE
GOING TO DIE FROM CORONAVIRUS
THIS YEAR.
AND SO, WE ALWAYS BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION OUT TO GUIDE PEOPLE
THAT WE KNOW WILL HELP THEM BE
HEALTHY WITH STATES RIGHTS, BUT
IT’S WHY WE PUT OUT THESE THREE
DAYS -- 30 DAYS TO STOP THE
SPREAD GUIDELINES.
THESE ARE ESSENTIALLY OUR
NATIONAL STAY-AT-HOME ORDER AND
WE’RE WORKING WITH GOVERNORS TO
FIGURE OUT THEIR NEEDS, THEIR
DESIRES.
ONE MORE IMPORTANT POINT, THE
NINE STATES THAT HAVEN’T YET
DONE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS ARE
STATES THAT ACTUALLY PRODUCE A
LARGE AMOUNT OF OUR FOOD.
SO THEY’RE STRUGGLING WITH
ISSUES CONCERNING HOW THEY CAN
PROVIDE FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY TO BE ABLE TO STAY AT
HOME, BUT RIGHT NOW WHAT I WOULD
SAY TO THOSE GOVERNORS IS IF YOU
CAN’T GIVE US A MONTH, GIVE US
WHAT YOU CAN.
GIVE US A WEEK.
GIVE US WHATEVER YOU CAN TO STAY
AT HOME DURING THIS PARTICULARLY
TOUGH TIME WE’RE GOING TO BE
HITTING OUR PEAK OVER THE NEXT
7-10 DAYS.
>> Chris: BUT DR. ADAMS,
THERE’S A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
OPIOIDS AND CIGARETTES.
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE DECIDE TO
USE OR NOT TO USE AND THE
CORONAVIRUS, WHICH PEOPLE CATCH.
IT’S NOT AN INDIVIDUAL CHOICE.
AND YOU KNOW, ONE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THAT HE IS
A WARTIME PRESIDENT, DURING
WORLD WAR II, FDR DIDN’T SAY,
WELL, IT’S UP TO EACH STATE TO
DECIDE TO DO, HE MOBILIZED THE
NATION.
AGAIN, WHY NOT A NATIONAL
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER?
THE CORONAVIRUS DOESN’T
RECOGNIZE STATES RIGHTS, SO DOES
THE FEDERAL ANALOGY REALLY WORK
HERE?
>> Dr. Adams: WELL, CHRIS, I
KNOW A WEEK AGO IS FOREVER AND
CORONAVIRUS TIME, BUT I WOULD
REMIND PEOPLE THAT WAS JUST A
WEEK AGO WHEN THE IDEA OF A
FEDERAL QUARANTINE FOR THE
NEW YORK CITY AREA WAS BEING
FLOATED IN GOVERNOR CUOMO SO
THAT WOULD BE LIKE DECLARING WAR
ON THE STATE.
THE GOVERNORS ARE INTENSELY
PROTECTIVE OF THEIR RIGHT, AND
RIGHTLY SO, TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE
WHAT’S BEST FOR THEIR STATES AND
WE ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN AS SCIENTISTS AND AS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE THINK THE
RIGHT THING IS FOR THEM TO DO
AND SO I JUST WANT EVERYONE TO
KNOW THAT, NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE,
THE SURGEON GENERAL IS SAYING NO
MATTER WHERE YOU ARE, STAY AT
HOME.
AT LEAST GIVE US A WEEK OR TWO
IF YOU CAN.
WE WANT YOU TO DO IT FOR 30 DAYS
BUT EVEN THOSE NINE STATES, GIVE
US WHAT YOU CAN SO WE CAN GET
THIS PEAK START TO COME DOWN ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Chris: DR. ADAMS, FOR DAYS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AS A
POSSIBLE TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
BUT YESTERDAY IN HIS BRIEFING HE
TOOK IT EVEN FURTHER, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
IN SOME CASES THEY ARE IN BAD
SHAPE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
I MAY TAKE IT AND I WILL HAVE TO
ASK MY DOCTORS ABOUT THAT BUT I
MAY TAKE IT.
>> Chris: DR. ADAMS, AS THE
NATION’S TOP PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIAL, ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
WITH PEOPLE TAKING AN UNPROVEN,
UNTESTED DRUG, EVEN PEOPLE WHO
DON’T ACTUALLY HAVE THE VIRUS?
>> Dr. Adams: HERE IS WHAT WE
HAVE ADVISED THE PRESIDENT AND
HERE’S WHAT I’VE HEARD HIM SAY
CONSISTENTLY.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN A TRAGIC
SITUATION WHERE THERE IN A
HOSPITAL OR A LOVED ONE IS IN
THE HOSPITAL WITH COVID-19, WE
WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT THEY COULD
POSSIBLY DO TO SAVE THEIR LIVES.
THERE IS SOME ACCOUNT, SOME
STORIES OUT THERE, REGARDING
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE HELPING AND
WE KNOW IT’S BEEN AVAILABLE FOR
YEARS, SO WE FEEL A LITTLE BIT
BETTER REGARDING ITS SAFETY THAN
WE DO ABOUT A COMPLETE NOVEL
DRUG, EVEN THOUGH THIS IS BEING
USED AT MUCH HIGHER DOSES, SO WE
JUST WANT TO ABLE TO FACILITATE
PHYSICIANS AND PATIENTS HAVING
THE CONVERSATION.
IF THAT’S I TELL PEOPLE, THAT’S
WHAT I FOR THE PRESIDENT TELL
PEOPLE.
>> Chris: FINALLY, I’VE GOT
ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT EAR,
DR. ADAMS, THE CDC NOW
RECOMMENDS THAT PEOPLE USE
FACE COVERINGS IN PUBLIC AND IN
FACT YOU ARE IN A CDC VIDEO IN
WHICH YOU SHOW PEOPLE HOW TO
MAKE A MASK THEMSELVES THAT THEY
CAN WEAR, BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS CLEAR THAT HE IS NOT GOING
TO BE FOLLOWING THAT GUIDANCE.
TAKE A LOOK HERE, SIR.
>> I THINK WEARING A FACE MASK
AS A GREAT PRESIDENT, PRIME
MINISTERS, DICTATORS, KINGS,
QUEENS, SOMEHOW I DON’T SEE IT
FOR MYSELF.
>> Chris: DOES THAT STATEMENT
BY THE PRESIDENT SEND A MIXED
MESSAGE ABOUT TAKING THIS
RECOMMENDATION SERIOUSLY?
>> Dr. Adams: WELL, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CDC GUIDELINES, THEY
ACTUALLY EMPHASIZED THAT NUMBER
ONE, THEY ARE VOLUNTARY, AND
NUMBER TWO, AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS AS THEY
ARE NOT A SUBSTITUTE FOR SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
I WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
YESTERDAY.
I’M GOING THERE IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOCTORS AND
SECRET SERVICE ARE TAKING PAINS
TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN REGARDS TO THE
PRESIDENT, THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND EACH OTHER, AND SO THE
PRESIDENT IS MAKING A CHOICE --
WHAT I WANT AMERICANS TO KNOW IS
IF YOU’RE GOING OUT IN PUBLIC
UNDER GOING TO BE CLOSER THAN
6 FEET OTHER PEOPLE, YOU CAN USE
A CLOTH FACIAL COVERING.
HERE’S MINE THAT I MADE, VERY
EASY TO USE.
AND IT PROTECTS YOU, CHRIS, FROM
ME.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THIS YOU ARE WEARING THIS NOT TO
PROTECT YOURSELF, YOU’RE USING
IT TO PROTECT YOUR NEIGHBOR, AND
THAT’S WHAT THIS WEEK IS GOING
TO BE ARE NOT WITHOUT.
PEOPLE WEARING CLOTH FACIAL
COVERINGS IF THEY HAVE TO GO OUT
IN PUBLIC TO PROTECT HER
NEIGHBOR.
IT’S GOING TO BE A TEST OF OUR
RESOLVE, IT’S GOING TO THE TEST
OF OUR LIVES, BUT I’M CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN COME OUT ON THE
OTHER SIDE BASED ON THE DATA
BASED ON WHAT I KNOW ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Chris: DR. ADAMS,
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME DURING
THESE VERY BUSY DAYS, PLEASE